hello everybody welcome
back to another stock indicators and
mathematics within python
video where we left off we were talking
about bollinger bands and in this video
we're actually going to go ahead and
calculate
the bollinger bands so as usual we're
going to need
two imports one is going to be import
numpy as mp and the other one's going to
be import time so we can add a sleeper
we're going to need our sample data and
that's going to be equals open
and if you don't have the sample data
let me just v-bop over there
there is a link in the description for
it and
well at least there should be anyways i
can't promise it until i actually make
the video in the description
but uh it's at centex.com sampledata.txt
so you can work with the exact same
sample data that i'm using
just do you know control a control c
make a
notepad file called sampledata.txt and
you're good to go
just make sure it's in the same
directory as this file
now uh anyway so we're going to open
sample
data.text obviously with the intention
to read also if you have been following
along my tutorial videos
it would behoove you to just save like
this top part because it's all pretty
much the same
every time we program it so you wouldn't
have to do this every time
um next to define that data it's date
close p high p low p open p
volume equals n p dot
load text what text do we want to load
oops oh we didn't actually split this
data all right
so let's do a split data equals sample
data
dot split and we need to split it by a
new lime
as usual guys sorry it is the morning i
do most of my videos in the morning
while i'm drinking my coffee doesn't
really work out too well
split data so that's the stuff that we
want to load the
delimiter is a comma
and finally unpack equals true so
we can assign it to a bunch of variables
like that
now uh we did just do a standard
deviation tutorial
video so i'm going to just run through
standard deviation
uh deviation and either you can go watch
that video
it is already here on youtube so you can
watch it or you can just type along with
me if you can type pretty fast
but i'm not really going to explain too
much so standard deviation
sd empty array sdda empty array
x is time frame while x is less than or
equal to the length of prices what do we
actually want to do well we're going to
go
array to consider equals prices
and starting point is x minus tf and
then
ending point is x and let's make some
space so we can continue writing this
bad boy
standard deviation equals ray to
consider dot std since standard
deviation is indeed
right here uh with numpy and python now
we want to do sd.open
uh stan dev
and actually just so it's the same as
everyone else's
we could stand dev like that sd
date dot append date
x and then don't forget your x plus
equals one
finally we return sd date sd and that's
the standard deviation
function where we can just pass through
some stuff so let's get to the bollinger
bands now
so bollinger bands pretty simple to find
bollinger bands and in here
we want to have our multiplier so
whatever we actually want remember the x
variable where i say you could just
choose anything it's usually two but
we'll let you guys
be able to be the masters of your
universe
uh and then tff for time frame and we
just i just
added an f purely so it doesn't conflict
with this so
because we pass tf through this
and it would just be best to not do that
so
next thing we want to do is uh just like
everything we have a b date that's gonna
be empty array
top band that's gonna be an empty array
bot band
actually has camel case uh top band two
top
band bot band empty array
uh mid band again empty array
x equals tff and then while x
is less than length of date what do we
want to
do we're going to say the current simple
moving average because
really we want to get that um just that
that current simple moving average point
we don't want the whole range of simple
moving averages
we just need that's that one point
because again um
right the calculation here was
just that that points simple moving
average plus that points
standard deviation of price times
whatever x is so that's
um we just want that one thing so what
we're going to do is we're going to call
uh do we even have we don't have a
moving average here do we know
well that's one we are definitely going
to copy and paste i don't feel like
writing that out
uh let's go the link for that will also
be in the description because this is
the starting point
so if you go either to my uh website or
you just click on the link in the
description just scroll down to moving
average
and we're going to just copy and paste
this function
just hit copy and paste it over here
if you are going to if you're planning
to follow the next video and actually
graph this
uh you might as well just copy and paste
that entire code as well
uh for your uh records since we're gonna
be there or just stay on that page
so cur sma back to work
is going to be equal to moving average
close p and again we're going to use
some fancy footwork x minus oops x minus
t
f f to x
uh using the time frame we've chosen
and then we actually see that creates an
array we want the negative first if
element
which will give us the last element and
what did i forget
um why is it doing that to me this
looks fine in my my uh my mind
this looks like a valid uh
somewhere we have not closed off what we
are
supposed to close off and this is it
uh we must have uh copy and paste it
over this
uh so unpack equals true you probably
didn't do that i remember typing out
unpacked equals true
anyway so that's why that was the indent
was throwing me off
uh again we want the negative first coil
okay
so uh so that gives us the current
simple moving average
then we want to get the current standard
deviation
so we're just going to say d just
because it does return the date
but we really just care about her sd
right which is the current standard
deviation
and that's going to equal a standard
deviation tff
close p and just so we have enough data
we're just going to say zero t f f and
then again we'll go
cur sd uh equals
cur sd
again we want the negative first element
there
uh now uh we're going to say t
b for top band equals oops
sma plus
uh cur sd times that multiplier whatever
multiplier we set bb not to be confused
with bollinger band that's bottom band
equals cur s m a
plus actually sorry that's minus
i'm open sd times
whatever that multiplier is and then
we're going to say
capital d equals date x
now we're going to append to all these
arrays that we've built up so we've got
top band bottom band mid man i'm just
going to copy that
come down here paste that
and do top band uh dot
append tb
don't forget to let's do a b date as
well i forgot that
b date dot append
a don't forget your x plus equals one
otherwise we will cry return b dates
top band uh bot band
and finally mid band
finally let's say
yeah that's good enough so d t b oops d
t b b b m b
equals bollinger bands
two and twenty and let's just for
kicks uh pretty much print d
print tv print bb print
uh so save that don't know why it
highlighted i must have fat fingered it
now run it see what happens
as long as you didn't get any like nasty
looking errors you probably did all
right
so the first value should be like 75 000
something or
something oh actually i'm sorry we're in
date stamp still we convert it later so
those are all of our dance stamps
no surprise uh the next thing we have is
the top band followed by the bottom band
it should be about the same price as the
stock
looks like it is uh since we were doing
starbucks
so top band bottom band middle band
should all be around like
50 to 60s uh since again at starbucks
so it looks like we've done it right and
the easiest way to find out is to
actually chart it up
and then you find out whether or not you
did it right so that's what we're going
to be doing in the next video is
taking this calculation here putting it
into matplotlib and our charting
application
and bring it up to see what we if we did
it right
so as always thanks for watching